deepmind controls nuclear fusion with
reinforcement learning yondercon
proposes a new architecture for world
models and according to a reliable
source it may be that today's large
neural networks are slightly conscious
welcome to ml news it's monday
[Music]
stop let me tell you about a feature
that i have just learned about recently
and it's crazy
this video is sponsored by weights and
biases and they have this alert thing
that you can send yourself emails
whenever your runs finish whenever your
runs crash and at your own choice so if
you log your experiments with weights
and biases and if you don't you should
in your code you can simply put this
alert statement right here and that will
send you an alert as soon as that piece
of the code is reached and for some
things it's obviously helpful to pack
that into some sort of an if statement
but you can send yourself updates about
your runs this way you won't have to
check them constantly so you can keep
track on the go if you go to your
account settings you'll see that
scriptable run alerts are already
activated that means whenever you put
the alert statement inside a code it
will actually send you an alert this
works whether it's in a script on a
server or in a jupyter notebook now you
can also activate notifications on email
or on slack whenever a run finishes or
if it crashes a certain amount of
minutes into the run this is super
helpful if you are dealing with various
problems such as nan's appearing after a
while and you want to keep constantly
checking your runs this could really
help you as i said these notifications
will show up in your email inbox or in
slack and they even have different
levels as you may be used to from
logging statements so this is an
absolutely cool method of keeping track
of your runs without having to check if
you go to this url wonderb dot me slash
ionic then you'll get straight into the
documentation of the alerts please check
it out there's also a collab to go along
with it showing you directly how to use
this thing and it's most beastly when
you combine it with configuration
frameworks such that if any run exhibits
any suspicious behavior you can
immediately get an alert to see what's
up thank you so much to wait and biases
for sponsoring this video again weights
and biases is your one stop shop for ml
ops whether you're a researcher or an
industry or a student or just someone
who's doing this at home for a hobby
they have something for you personal use
is free forever and please check out the
link to learn more about their awesome
alerts feature let's get into the video
all right we have a lot to get through
today so buckle up the first story
deepmind has a new blog post called
accelerating fusion science through
learned plasma control now this is
insane they control plasma in a nuclear
fusion reactor using deep reinforcement
learning so this thing is a research
apparatus called the variable
configuration tokamak and it produces
this thing called plasma inside of it
now the goal here is to generate and
control this plasma over time which
would allow us to harness the energy of
nuclear fusion how exactly i'm not sure
but it's important that we can do it yet
controlling this thing is really hard
there are a number of magnetic coils
that are super strong that go around and
inside of this device and decisions
about how to steer them need to be made
in very short time and this is a highly
non-linear complex problem so deepmind
used a simulated environment in which
they trained a reinforcement learning
policy in order to steer these coils
this augments the traditional control
system that was already in place and
allows them better controllability of
this plasma this is really important
because if the plasma is mishandled like
if it touches a wall or anything like
this that can cause a lot of damage to
the apparatus now hold on hold on right
here are you telling me that deep
reinforcement learning you know this
thing or you know you know that thing
right here
yeah
yeah that controls a nuclear reactor
absolutely fantastic oh yes yes please
more plasma more plasma right here right
here right here yeah more uh plasma is
gone well in any case they do actually
achieve stable configurations of plasma
including ones that the human
controllers couldn't do before such as
this droplet configuration on the left
there is a paper in nature to go along
with it and this represents a
significant step towards making nuclear
fusion more plausible for possible
future energy source
the google ai blog has a piece called
good news about the carbon footprint of
machine learning training in which they
analyze how they've reduced the carbon
emissions of machine learning training
in the last years they have this
principle called 4m which stands for
model machine mechanization and map
optimization into which they categorize
the various things that you can do to
make your machine learning model
training use less energy and therefore
emit less carbon this starts by figuring
out smarter model architectures
themselves by using more efficient
machines by pooling machines into data
centers where you can cool them very
effectively and then by locating these
data centers on the planet where energy
is maybe more green or more readily
available and emits less carbon as such
they say these four practices can reduce
energy by 100x and emissions by 1000 x
it's pretty cool they have a plot right
here and no these aren't carbon
emissions these are actually reduction
in carbon emission i know the plot is a
little bit weird but a y value of 1
would be the 2017 state and then yeah
now
reduction now at least part of this
comes as a response to a different piece
of work by the university of
massachusetts which completely
overestimated the carbon emissions of a
previous work by google on neural
architecture search so google had this
paper on an architecture called the
evolved transformer which they found by
neural architecture search one of the
goals of the architecture search was to
build a more performant more efficient
model which the evolved transformer is
so this external study had estimated the
cost of doing this architecture search
and it turns out according to google's
own numbers they overestimated the
amount of carbon emissions by 88 times
that's an 8
800 error rate what's even crazier is
this right here they say unfortunately
some subsequent papers misinterpreted
the nas estimate as the training cost
for the model it discovered so the study
was criticizing the architecture search
itself now given the fact that you do
architecture search you can actually
waste some resources because you're
going to get them in again once you use
the discovered model if it's really that
much better but apart from that they did
criticize the architecture search they
overestimated by 88 times and now other
papers come in and they just misquote
the study and they claim that the
estimate is the cost of training one
evolved transformer model google writes
in reality training the evolve
transformer model on the task examined
by the umass researchers following the
4m best practices takes 120 tpuv2 hours
and costs 40 and emits only 2.4 kilogram
of carbon dioxide that is an error rate
of a factor of 120
thousand now i'm not saying there is
nothing to be worried right here about
the cost of training large machine
learning models there certainly is and
within google they say that machine
learning uses about 10 to 15 percent of
google's total energy use split into
three fifths for inference and two
fifths for training so that's not
nothing there seems to be a narrative
about big companies bad which i get you
know understandable but still if the
desire to complain becomes stronger than
actually looking at true numbers the
criticism might be a bit misplaced and
yes these big companies train larger and
larger models but they're also building
more and more effective data centers and
these larger models could potentially
down the road save a lot of stuff and
advances beyond the need for
carbon-based energy much faster but i
have one issue with this article whoever
thought it was it was a good idea to
call this thing good news about the
carbon footprint like could you make a
title that anymore screams lobbying
piece is like some christians at your
door have you heard the good news about
the carbon footprint of machine learning
training i mean the title here almost
invalidates the article itself but i'm
gonna believe them on their numbers
[Music]
the meta ai blog which surprisingly is
still hosted at ai.facebook.com
wait wait the certificate is made out to
facebook inc they never changed their
name it's all just a big conspiracy the
metaverse isn't real in any case the
meta ai blog has a new post called yan
lacan on a vision to make ai systems
learn and reason like animals and humans
and other than implying that humans
apparently aren't animals it details a
new vision of a
broad architecture guidelines for
building the next generation of
autonomous intelligence now diagrams
like these have existed for a while you
know the different modules that we need
in order to interact with the world in
order to build autonomous systems but
the specific focus here is on the green
bubble called world model and the main
ingredient lukon suggests here is called
jepa the joint embedding predictive
architecture now this pulls together a
number of threads that young lacan has
been pursuing and advocating for in
recent years such as energy-based models
such as self-supervised predictive
learning and he advocates strongly for
using regularizers instead of
contrastive learning now all of this by
itself is of course nothing new meta
previously facebook has investigated all
of these things in a number of
architectures which have been really
successful but to get it together into
one model is sort of a suggestion by le
carr and he says they haven't built this
model yet but it is a plan on the
horizon the cool thing about this model
is it can be composed for example it can
be made to do short and long range
predictions it can do supervised as well
as unsupervised as well as a
reinforcement learning task it can be
arranged in a temporal and hierarchical
fashion to learn layers of abstractions
and build up plans into the future
focusing on world models is definitely a
breakaway of other reinforcement
learning efforts which directly try to
go model free from input and perception
to action without having some sort of an
intermediate model now if this all seems
pretty vague to you then yes it's just a
plan for now but it sounds pretty cool
young luck has also given an extensive
talk about this which is on his youtube
channel yes young lucan is a youtuber
bet you didn't know that so leave a
comment right here if you would like me
to make a dedicated video about what we
know so far about the japa architecture
and how it might work
researchers from the muksplunk institute
of neurobiology publish a paper called a
biophysical account of multiplication by
a single neuron investigating a real
neuron biological neuron in a fruit fly
that can do multiplication or something
akin to multiplication which is really
cool because a lot of models and what we
knew so far about neurons we're always
dealing with sort of input output linear
relationships so we could weigh inputs
and we could add them but we could not
necessarily multiply them or there
wasn't necessarily a mechanism by which
that could happen these researchers
study fruit flies under different visual
stimuli and discover that under the
right conditions they can see a
multiplication like non-linear behavior
in a neuron if you want to learn more
about this check out the paper it's on
nature
[Music]
lillian wang publishes
emojisearch.app which is a pretty neat
search tool where you can find emojis
pickle
yeah works nicely so the code of this is
online it essentially does a call to the
open ai api gets embeddings from the new
embedding endpoint and then compares
those embeddings of whatever you entered
to the embeddings of a predefined list
of emojis pretty simple application of
the embeddings api and works pretty well
for the stuff i've tried if you want
some inspiration check it out
we've previously reported on r5 which is
a pawn on the
where you can view any paper as an html
page instead of a pdf and we're happy to
report that r5 is now an official sub
project in the archive labs so hopefully
pretty soon you'll be able to have a
unified experience across archive where
you can go to website instead of a dom
pdf
ilia sudskiver has tweeted out it may be
that today's large neural networks are
slightly conscious and the whole world
came crushing down this to me is
essentially kind of a shower thought and
just you know it's twitter you just
tweet it out it's a musing it's an
interesting thought it may lead to an
interesting discussion who knows however
the world seemed to freak out about it
and i just can't understand that people
legitimately get mad at this like either
you're looking to get mad at something
or you're just so far down some rabbit
hole of construing this as bad i don't
know now of course there were legitimate
responses and people discussing this in
seriousness but then also
the news happened futurism.com openai
chief says advanced ai may already be
conscious
interestingengineering.com openai top
scientist says a.i might already be
conscious researchers respond furiously
furiously you hear but there were some
brave souls coming to help another one
from futurism.com mit researchers don't
ignore that possibility that ai is
becoming conscious daily mail artificial
intelligence expert warns that there may
already be a slightly conscious ai out
in the world oh no
and interestingly you see the phenomenon
that happens often with media in that
they just kind of translate the may and
could to
open ai co-founder ilya sudskiver claims
artificial intelligence is conscious is
experts called out his claim as being
off the mark and called him full of it
like the word experts has got to become
a meme sometimes in the near future like
as soon as you start a sentence with
experts say is like who who listens
nobody listens especially if their
argument is you're full of it oh ah ah
the convincingness oh no gee i've just
meditated three days about the
metaphysics of what could and couldn't
be consciousness and the inner workings
of deep learning but now that you're
saying i'm full of it ah that does it
thank you experts again futurism
researchers furious over claim that ai
is already conscious they're mad
oh no
they're mad anything but mad not the mad
and the daily star conscious ai may
already exist as expert receives
backlash over terrifying warning well
there you have it i personally have no
stake in this i just found it funny how
the media reacted right here if you want
my opinion and and this is not me
coming up with this uh by myself it's
helped by a lot of people is that
consciousness whatever it is is clearly
a physical process that happens
somewhere in the brain as a result of
matter interactions and therefore it's
absolutely possible that there is
something like consciousness happening
in a non-human brain system secondly i
think consciousness is not something
that is binary it's not like you're
either conscious or you're not most
things in biology are not that clear cut
i mean even the concept of alive is sort
of undermined by the existence of
viruses and i think the two qualifiers
here first the it may be and second the
slightly conscious work very nicely with
that now of course a lot of people are
pointing out that we don't actually have
a good definition of what consciousness
is we don't know too much about it to be
able to make these kinds of statement
which is absolutely true guaranteed
however very often those are the same
people that say absolutely not our large
neural networks conscious and it's like
well which one do you want in any case
carry on
there's a new paper by meta ai and inria
claiming that vision models are more
robust and fair when pre-trained on
uncurated images without supervision so
what they've done is they've gone out
into the internet and they just
collected without any filters a
humongous amount of images no processing
no filtering and they've just trained
the models on those images and it turns
out on a lot of these metrics about
fairness and robustness that model
performed better than models that were
trained on curated data sets such as
imagenet now of course this is
interesting because it cuts directly
against the people that claim often very
loudly that you need to heavily curate
your input data you need to heavily
curate your training process otherwise
the models they will become oh so bad
because they'll pick up all of these
stereotypes and all of the biases in the
training data and while i generally
agree with that statement the evidence
here seems to be that exposing just the
model to a wide variety of data and the
diversity of data may actually achieve
that in practice and if you ask me i'd
rather go with the people that actually
tried it out and measured it rather than
the people who are simply claiming we
should do something and how it would
turn out on a more philosophical level i
think that much like humans we shouldn't
shield our models from bad material
instead i think we should expose our
models to all sorts of material all
sorts of inputs and then build the types
of models that can actually reason
across those inputs and reason why
particular things in particular context
may be appropriate or inappropriate or
warranted and yeah that's just my
opinion leave yours in the comments
this project is pretty cool clip pusso
is a system that comes out of a paper
and it uses clip together with a
differentiable renderer for drawings in
order to create sketches of pictures in
various levels of abstractions as you
can see right here most notably this
process is based on clip and does not
require a sketch data set to be present
and because the sketches are
parameterized as bezier curves and not
pixels you can do things like change the
brush styles and use all kinds of weird
things that you can do in vector
graphics as opposed to the classic pixel
graphics check out their project website
it's pretty cool to see what the model
outputs and uh yeah give it a shot
[Music]
all right here's our section of helpful
things first helpful thing is this book
right here natural language processing
with transformers by lewis tunstall
leandro von vera and thomas wolfe now
what's interesting about this book right
here other than it might be interesting
to a lot of you is that this one comes
with a dedication it says hyonik have
you heard of them transformers already
we think they're pretty cool maybe
you'll learn a thing or two about them
in this book the book itself goes into
concepts of how transformers work how
they operate on language but also the
direct code examples of the hugging face
library so essentially an all-in-one
tutorial on natural language processing
in 2022. thank you very much the book is
available on amazon as an ebook and also
as a
well
paper i think it's called paper so you
know give it a try all right some more
helpful things tb parse is a library
that parses tensorboard events very cool
if your stuff outputs these event files
that you want to read with tensorboard
but you actually want to import them
somewhere else
this may be the way to go a normal lib
is a library for benchmarking developing
and deploying deep learning anomaly
detection algorithms akb48 is a database
of articulation objects these are
objects that you can somehow interact
with by articulation so
books bottles knives dispensers
compasses glue sticks nail clippers so
this is a database of properties and 3d
models of those things evosax is a
library that contains jax-based
evolution strategy algorithms this
library is by robert lange you might
know him he's a writer in the ml space
and it implements a number of different
evolution strategy algorithms in jax
related to this google releases evo jax
yes the previous one was evo sex now
it's evo jax this is hardware
accelerated neural evolution now evojax
focuses on the acceleration the
distribution and the efficient methods
of rolling out episodes in neural
evolution algorithms while evo sax
focuses on implementing the actual
strategies now what's cool is that
robert has already made a pull request
to evojax and the two projects are
integrated with one another so if you're
into evolutionary algorithms give these
two projects a try text less lib by meta
ai research is a library for text-less
spoken language processing that's
essentially nlp without an intermediate
text representation going from sound
waves directly to whatever the task
output should be standard sim is a
synthetic data set for retail
environments so this is a rendered data
set of uh
stores like the inside of stores it's
pretty cool and it looks like super real
except it's too clean like it's way too
clean patrick von platten tweets that
new t5 checkpoints are to be found in
the hugging phase hub this is after
research by e-tai and others who trained
a lot of t5 checkpoints in various sizes
and analyzed their scaling properties so
now there are a number of t5 checkpoints
that are potentially much more
performant than the original ones they
are available in large and small
especially one is called t5 efficient
tiny n18 or nl8 who knows but it does
require less than 100 megabytes of
memory which is very small for a
transformer mod synth is by its own
description a huge data set for
pedestrian detection and tracking in
urban scenarios creating by exploiting
the highly photorealistic video game
grand theft auto 5. so yeah gta 5
in-game footage is now used to create
high quality data sets this is how far
we've come as a civilization better hope
sasquatch isn't in there hash nerf
pytorch is a pure pie torch
implementation of the paper on neural
graphics primitives so neural graphics
primitives or instant ngp was a paper by
nvidia that made it possible to render
nerfs a lot faster now that
implementation was only available in c
plus so the researchers here have ported
it to pytorch and that is not as fast
but it allows researchers to play around
with it diffracts is a library of
numerical differential equation solvers
in jacks they're auto differentiatable
and gpu capable excellent finrl is a
deep reinforcement learning for
quantitative finance if you ever wanted
to predict the stock market using deeper
enforcement learning don't do it it
doesn't work but for anything else use
finnrl the ai nordics discord is
releasing swedish models specifically
there is a bird large swedish case which
is bird trained on swedish excellent
they also have a gpt model in swedish
but they're only giving it out if they
like you because of potential misuse of
the model well i guess whatever floats
their booty mold is a benchmark about
long documents and multi-task learning
it's a set of six nlp tasks where the
input consists of at least 10 000 words
and has various tasks such as
translation summarization question
answering and more interestingly there
seems to be tasks where you need to
create an output that is even longer
than the input text breaching is a
framework for attacks against privacy in
federated learning so federated learning
is this idea that users kind of keep
their own data and just kind of send you
back gradients for your models and there
are a lot of techniques that claim that
this can be done with privacy sort of
guaranteed that i can send around my
gradients without the central instance
being able to reconstruct my personal
data so this framework includes a number
of what's called gradient inversion
attacks that allow you to do it
nonetheless so it's a little bit like
the field of adversarial examples if
you're interested in this kind of stuff
this might be a cool way to start
metashift is a data set of data sets for
evaluating contextual distribution
shifts and training conflicts so this is
a benchmark about distribution shifts
and one thing it does for example it
presents objects in various different
contexts to analyze how models react to
that for example on the bottom here you
see a cat on a keyboard in a sink in a
box with a remote control you know just
cat things so it's really cool that we
go beyond sort of the classic one image
is one object of one class setting and
take the next steps in order to deploy
these models in the wider world all
right that was already it for helpful
things well not already that that was a
lot of helpful things
our last story for the night uh the
verge writes the us copyright office
says an ai can't copyright its art now
if you click through you'll get to an
article of urbasm and for whatever
reason their background picture has a
bot in it but okay cool but this turns
out to be about an old friend of ours
it's dr steven taller the inventor of a
system called dabus that makes
autonomous inventions apparently now it
also makes art now tyler has previously
applied for patterns of inventions that
his system has made and actually
succeeded in some countries and failed
in others now apparently he's also
trying to patent his art sorry the ai's
art of course now i've looked into his
systems and they seem kinda sketchy to
the point where i'm not sure if if these
are just kind of uh
sort of pixelated versions of things
that exist and and that's just
disturbing i mean that's just an image
of einstein overlaid on a tunnel but
yeah dr taller seems to be on a mission
to uh establish that ai can own patents
but he's now been smashed down by the
copyright office that says that in order
to grant the patent there must be a
human intervention so their definition
of patentable creativity includes
essentially the interaction of the the
human intellect or the human brain with
the world now that is the law currently
but who knows how this goes on in the
future it's a difficult question because
for the first time probably it is
probably legit to ask who owns the
copyright of ai produced stuff and
whether or not this counts as an
invention and then who made the
invention and if ai is capable of being
an inventor what kind of implication
does this have down the line it's a set
of interesting questions but i don't
have the answer to those let me know
what you think as always this was it for
ml news it was wonderful to have you
here please check out weights and biases
1db dot me slash yannick and i'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
you